Bisher konnten nur große oder auch mittelgroße
konzerne strom verkaufen in zukunft soll das aber jeder können blog
Chains machen es möglich also datenblock hätten ihr könnt euch das vorstellen wie eine art digitales register dass alle transaktionen
aufzeichnet das hat viele vorteile beispielsweise
Ist es für alle teilnehmer transparent jeder kann reingucken mit hilfe von block chains können also auch privatkunden strom, ihrer
Solarzellen oder aus den batterien ihrer elektroautos verkaufen wenn es sich lohnt
Wie bald vielleicht jeder mit strom handeln kann
Jetzt den klick zum science and fiction herzlich willkommen und zum schluss gibt es noch eine kleine überraschung
Blog chains kann man quasi als eine art technische handelsplattform bezeichnen die die teilnehmer von transaktionen
unabhängiger macht für viele verschiedene projekte, des nachbarschafts handelt sind dezentrale blog fans von enormer bedeutung
zum beispiel in der ökostrom szene normalerweise wird der preis für strom unter anderem durch die gesetzgebung
Netzbetreiber und energieversorger bestimmt doch blog chains machen es auf diesem feld jetzt möglich dass verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
selbst mitmischen wer also eine
photovoltaik anlage auf seinem hausdach hat oder diejenigen die eine ladesäule in der garage haben können mit hilfe von block chains ihre produzierten
kilowattstunden in kapital umwandeln indem sie ihren strom verkaufen die programmcodes der block james beinhalten dabei beispielsweise
transaktions protokolle mit allen möglichen infos damit die bestellten kilowattstunden strom an die empfängerin oder den empfänger transportiert
werden können die daten blöcke sind dezentral verschlüsselt
Validiert also auf ihre gültigkeit überprüft und gespeichert alle prozesse wie beispielsweise
Die buchung oder der erhalt werden in den daten lockt hätten gespeichert ohne dass etwas verloren geben kann denn alles ist
transparent und zwar für alle dem netzwerk sind ein größeres projekt das beweist dass das technisch funktioniert läuft dem buckland hier
teilen besitzerinnen und besitzer von solarstromanlagen
Ihren strom mit anderen auch in deutschland ist das konzept bereits in die praxis umgesetzt worden die rwe tochter innogy
Ist an der idee beteiligt das besitzerinnen und besitzer von elektroautos ihre ladebox
zu hause teilen kann damit auch andere strom tanken können dazu meldet man sich mit einer app an
Durch smart contract also auf deutsch smarte verträge die im programmcode vorliegen werden die ladebuchse freigegeben in diesem netzwerk sind
Mittlerweile rund 1200 öffentliche und private ladestation angemeldet und es funktioniert ungewiss ist allerdings ob das technisch
So klappt wenn es immer mehr elektroautos. Geben sollte denn das bedeutet mehr datendurchsatz denn dann soll das sogenannte
Schalding ein wort konstrukt aus charging laden und sharing teilen zum einsatz kommt dabei werden die blöcke nicht mehr
im gesamten netzwerk sondern voneinander
getrennten bruchstücken validiert also auf ihre echtheit gecheckt auch wenn dieses konzept große vorteile mit sich bringt gibt es auch einen schwerwiegenden
nachteil eine studie vom kölner
energiewirtschaftlichen
forschungsinstitut für energy research und szenarios zeigt jetzt das blog chains nicht
wirtschaftlich sind denn der preis für den strom wird durch viele aspekte in die höhe getrieben beispielsweise durch steuern
einspeisetarife und netzentgelten nachteilig ist auch dass eine stabile versorgung nicht gewährleistet werden kann
Denn der netzbetrieb kann sich nicht auf eine kontinuierliche
strohmann lieferung bzw
Abnahme einstellen die netzbetreiber wissen somit nicht wie hoch das angebot und der bedarf sind doch es gibt hoffnung eine blockt chain lösung von ibm
soll engpässe
Im stromnetz verhindern ihr vorteil sie kann größere mengen an batterien für den stabilen netzbetrieb zugänglich machen die größte herausforderung
branchenübergreifende blog chain technologien zu optimieren besteht darin die
transaktions rate zu erhöhen bei der block chain für die krypto währung bitcoin
Gegen etwa sieben transaktionen pro sekunde viel zu wenig nicht nur für den energiebereich die lösung könnte eine sogenannte con
soziale blog chain sein hier sind meist unternehmen die betreiber somit sind die
identitäten der teilnehmer bekannt und damit ist dann auch das konsens protokoll weniger aufwendig ist wird deutlich weniger energie
für die block chains benötigt und bytes werden weniger verstummt 1000 transaktion werden dann tatsächlich pro sekunde möglich
intelligente ladetechnik wird dann
Mit den smart contracts kombiniert die batterien nehmen also strom auf wenn es zu viel davon gibt andersherum können sie ihn auch wieder einspeisen wenn
Frage steigt, um das angebot. Zu klein ist auch das hamburger softwarehaus
proton baut auf eine ähnliche idee enerchange
basiert auf ten dam and eine viel leistungsfähiger blog chain plattform wobei in jeder sekunde ein blog gebildet wird im vergleich bei der smart
Kontaktplattform smi um passiert dies alle 20 sekunden bei der digitalen währung bitcoin sogar nur alle 10 minuten ein blog fasst mehrere
transaktionen so dass bei optimalen bedingungen bis zu
10.000 transaktionen enthalten sein können ende des jahres wollen unternehmen wie rwe und total den energiehandel auf entertain
betreiben noch kann man kaum abschätzen wie sich diese ganzen block zehn varianten zukünftig gegen, zentrale digitalisierungs techniken werden
experten experten sagen eine zwischenlösung voraus die zentrale und dezentrale techniken kombiniert ebenso
Genauso wie sich wohl auf die stromwirtschaft in zukunft aus vielen kleinen und großen
erzeugungs einheiten zusammensetzen wird auf jeden fall steht eine revolution
des energiemarktes bevor in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von technology review ist dieses video entstanden und speziell für pixum zuschauer
Habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf diesen link klickt den könnte auch gerne weitergeben
Technology review ist der absolute hammer und ja hier geht es zu einem weiteren video dass wir mit dieser tollen redaktion zusammen gemacht haben
der verkehr der zukunft
Vorbild china klick drauf wenn es euch interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann